There's this thing that exists,
this,
this multi-headed snake,
and it's got this infinity problem.
It's everywhere.
That's that little circle down there,
and the problem is,
well,
what do you do with it?
You cut off one head,
seven more,
grow.
That's the eternal problem of life and
the problem is they're there.
There is the category of problems in
life and it ain't going anywhere.
And so the question is can you deal with
the whole category at the same time?
That's the thing.
That's how to be in the world is to deal
with that category all at the same time.
And so how did,
how did human beings,
what did they come up with as a
solution?
And that's so cool too,
because the solution they come up with
not only was the heroism that allows you
to approach what you're terrified by and
what you find offensive and to learn
from it,
but also the idea of sacrifice and that
was played out by cultures everywhere,
including human sacrifice.
And you think what the hell was up with
those crazy bastard so long ago?
They were sacrificing to the gods all
the time,
but kind of clueless behavior was that
burned something and please God burned
something valuable and please God.
It's like,
what was with,
what were they thinking?
Well,
they weren't stupid.
Those people,
if they were stupid,
we wouldn't be here.
They were not stupid and believe me,
they lived under a lot harsher
conditions than we do.
So those were some tough people,
man.
You know,
back then you'd last about 15 minutes.
And so you don't want to be thinking of
your ancestors as stupid,
like there's no real evidence that we're
much different cognitively than we were
150,000
years ago.
So anyways,
sacrifice.
What does that mean?
Sacrifice?
Well,
it's a discovery man.
It's the discovery of the future.
It's like the future is actually the
place where there is threat and it's
always going to be there.
So what do you do?
You make sacrifices in the present so
that the future is better,
right?
Everyone does that.
That's what you're doing right now.
That's what you're doing here.
That's what your parents are doing when
they pay money to send you to
university,
they think let you can bargain with
reality.
It's amazing.
You can bargain with reality.
You can forestall gratification now and
it'll pay off at a place in time that
doesn't even exist yet.
It's like,
who wouldn't believe that?
It's like that's a miracle that that
occurs and it's not like people just
figured that out over night,
you know,
we were champs for Christ's sake.
Like how are we going to come up with an
idea like that while it's like,
well,
we thought about it for 7 million years
and you know,
we got to the point where we could kind
of act it out,
but we didn't know what we were doing,
but it was a emerge just like a dream.
It was.
So the terror of the future is a dream
and his solution to the terror,
the dream of the terror of the future is
another dream.
And it,
it comes out in mythology and in fantasy
and in drama where you act out the
sacrifice and then it's a step on the
way to full understanding.
So we can say sacrifice instead of doing
it,
you know,
although we still do it,
it's just not concretized like it used
to be.
We do abstractly and we all have faith
that it will work,
you know,
and we also set up our society so that
it'll work.
And one thing about,
you know,
I'm not a fan of moral relativism for a
variety of reasons,
partly because I think it's an,
it's an extreme form of cowardice.
But anyways,
apart from that,
no,
no.
There's minimal ways that you can set up
a society that will work and so one of
them is,
is that the society has to be set up so
that your sacrifices will pay off or you
won't work,
and then the society will die.
And so it has to make promises.
People have to make promises to one
another.
And that's what money is.
Money is a promise that your sacrifice
will pay off in the future.
That's what money is.
And so if the society is stable,
you can store up your work right now.
You can sacrifice your impulses and you
can work and you can store up credit for
the future and then you can make the
future a better place,
but society has to be stable enough to
allow for that.
Hyperinflation will do you in.
So the promise that's implicit in the
currency is the promise that what you're
doing now will pay off in the future,
and if people don't have that promise,
then what?
We know what they do because in in gangs
for example,
and say gangs in North America,
the time horizon of the gang members
shrinks rapidly because they don't
really expect to be alive much past 21.
And so they get really impulsive and
violent and like,
why the hell not?
That's what you do when,
when the future doesn't matter,
when it's not real,
you default back to living in the moment
and you take what you can get right now
and no wonder because you don't know if
you're going to be around in a in a year
and you get whatever you can.
Well you can bloody well get it and
that's like anarchy that state.
And so you don't want to live in,
some people like to live in that state
because they're really wired for that,
you know,
and so they're much more comfortable in
those conditions.
They're,
they're kind of like warrior types,
I would say in some sense.
But you know,
for most people that's just where that
stress will just do 10,
you know,
the stress of a life like that.
So.